salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo salut fab salut
cave
bon bah ça part très vite on n'a pas
trop le temps de parler donc carson avec
les blancs contre creamery courrier sur
l'image
donc on est à louvain et c'est une anti
berlinoise avec des trois fous ces cinq
coups classiques pioncer 3 et là
peut-être des 5
oui le coup choisi par craignent donc
des cinq puis contre attaque directement
le centre c'est ça avant tu laisses le
pion aux cinq ans la raclée crawl
clouage mais bon ça va ce dynamique et
c'est un truc à la mode
donc on a une structure symétrique comme
la simple entoure ces trois bien placé
par rapport auxquels ces 6es du coupe
les oreilles et le pied des deux peut
venir en c4 attaqué le centre
non tu n'as plus d'oreilles tokaï ces
six joueurs et il a des oreilles
arias froid il a dès branchies quoi
quelque part mais je préfère qu'il y ait
des huit qui avait lui aussi se retrouve
une oreille enfin bref les oreilles la
dgal très intéressant est ce que tu
penses que vous caraïbéen pourrait
devoir aussi pour les blancs bon pour
troller oui après lequel des deux va
t'es plutôt déjà bien puisqu'il peut
aller sur ces quatre donc c'est pas
plutôt se barrer que foulées saint qui
n'avaient rien à faire maintenant au 2
août pour bouger fou et enfin un cheval
mort très réfléchie magnus cramique a
pas mal dans cette partie on voit qu'ils
bougent la question avec sa main banier
a pris une pièce et ils à tours en fait
qui en est fait très bien tourner
sénégal fendant jeune homme le fousseret
bright food et 3 nous empêche les c4
on pouvait pas le coup d'or bien sûr que
les c4 et c6 qui a enfermé le flou donc
maintenant l on peut juste ramener ce
qui a aidé de six bons malgré ses quatre
mares qui l'affaiblît pas un peu la case
f5 avec ce coup peut-être que par la
douceur fou aussi sans se prendre deux
trucs je sais pas ces canadiens belges
de nouveau les oreilles enfin moi je
sais pas peut-être se fait caillasser
des deux mois sylvain jutteau propose
une norme a du coup je pense que la
séquence de côté plutôt pas mal pour
pour mac guff bizarrement lui
l'améliorer va trouver les cinq bons sur
le coq et en arrivent même truc de fond
v5 on mange à celles ci sont prévues sur
le 5 mais bon je trouve quand même des
pertes de temps pour un énorme bon ça
reste quand même accroché mais c'est
vrai que c'est plutôt les blancs qu'un
fps bien placé est toujours un kayak
5000 visites attaf quatre femmes -
doublement web votre note le fond elles
font toutes façons roche deux fins g3
dégage la fois f1 team mais d'ailleurs
une sur cale f4 peut-être faire du
cavaly pro 5 1 foot qu'il fasse gaffe on
entendu qu'il prend 1,3 tout ça qu'elle
me fait des mêmes ficelles trois roches
de l'orage et je défends on tue avec le
roi je monte à la volée la dame c'est de
défendre plus en f2 donc c'est pas mal
il vous de plus en plus vite la pièce
d'aller très très chauvin chronique
saison sam ly des fourrages trop en
français 5 et 6 les noirs prennent
eux-mêmes trois mondes l'empreinte de la
tour des flandres cavaliers ou peut-être
dû cavaler himself et ça fout princes 3
qui est des cinq ne sais pas peut-être
tmg 10 mars au pied même en pire suite
ou reprendre un tel montant mais fo et
fit jeu cofisaf des menaces mais bon
rush de maintenant d'autant bien
d'autant mieux ou cavailles age 2
peut-être moins qu'un maillage de pas
mal aussi
tu as eu une oreille angers 4 mais très
intéressant le son la case g4 matière
mais ok bon orage d'eau sinon ça juste
là pas trop mal quoi marges et le vin
c'est quand même le truc classique
kefu et 6 ont peut-être tour a bien un
enfin bah pourquoi pas trois d'un coup
très décent calé f des deux sinon l'idée
c'est juste d'enlever ce cavalier faire
j'ai trois etc
ça me va aussi il développe ça va très
bientôt leur démission non est très
logique un parfait à une tour tu
développes tour sur une colonne ouvert
très bien c'est très intéressant de
développer son collègue
non mais sur ce genre de beauté spa tout
instrument un voile a forcément un très
bon coup ouais je sens les cinq de leurs
chroniques est très confiant maintenant
plus à jouer ce coup d'une grande
compréhension qu'on aille il se dit j'ai
attendu j'ai attendu attendu l'arbitré
barré et finalement j'en vois le pire
encore juste en toile et 5 parce qu'on
veut faire genre dame allait faire dame
c'est un t1 je ne veux plus voir son de
change est simple mais s'incline jeu
simplifié dessus même qui avait déjà
géré ma foi se passe si mal cavalia les
deux
peu importe gemecs alléger un qe2 puis
je me réjouis qu'hier j'ai trois
randonnées statut atchaka égéen fulham
piégeurs tape le coup juste comme ça je
crois d'agen plage 3 c'est ça défend un
peu de tout peut-être faire du
impressionné avec quatre fous eux deux
g3 que ringer 3pl de tanger
non je te prends ta tour comme sage
actif à tour à 8,35 à idées 2 ok mais il
veut quand même faire j'ai trois fous
d'elle à hefei menace fargy 3 food donc
quelque part alors cet échange de tours
souvent on dit aux amateurs de pas faire
parce que tu te laisses le contrôle à
l'adversaire et c'est la peur du club ac
va d'ailleurs pas même là mais le truc
c'est que le pion à 5 de vin devient
moins bien protégés donc j'imagine que
peut-être magnus a décidé de kabylie b3
simplement l'attaqué à cinq des petits
trucs comme ça subtil mais perd du temps
on va vous déconseiller d'échanger sur
une colonne la fnb 6 immédiatement tu
n'as grimpe à manger trois longues et
donc c'est le plan de rompre avec les
blancs on va tenir la case f4 tout ça et
peut-être à suivre fou aux deux époux g4
avec l'idée donc bah si on peut changer
de case blanche très bien que c'est
quand même un trou entre 5 kg 3
maintenant que tu protèges lacanau qui a
tué mon cavalier de jeu vient quand même
des gages bon l'idée bien sûr si j'ai
pranger prend le foudroie ton ferme et
donc les noirs ne perdent pas de pièces
et du coup ils les laissent pas l'fou
arrivée angers 4 puisque sur faut deux
temps kas le fou c'est très intéressant
donc le tâtre on peut enlever le qui a
aidé deux maintenant comme son menacera
2.94 on a un des cases de retraite même
et dû l'enlever pour le métro ben tiens
matière je ferais bien f3b 3 en fait
pour commencer je protège un peu mon
cavale comme ça il y aura jamais de
tactique avec sky prend à croire puisque
je l'aï bien tes vrais matchs 3 et
accueille ces quatre qui restent sont
prises du bonheur un choix de chiens b3
je protège donc tout trouvé la fiole
quoi bon oui tu nous tiens mes droits
très intéressant hop on défend on défend
nombre de locaux en guadeloupe oui on
est tellement heureux que moi un peu
d'eau à la minute où je suis tourné mes
vives idée qui prend une pièce il a fait
tourner en sarre après c'est fini
le truc est capturée quoi
tourner dans tous les sens moral que tu
le menace une islamique non je rends moi
cette pièce vie est finie
bon c'est parce qu'ils le fun qu'on
pouvait cela peut-être une petite nul
entre esuba et miss avait sa partie de
cartes n intéresse pas du tout aller
jeter un oeil ici ou là très symétriques
tout ça mais regrette le cavalier des
marchés food 2 donc les b2 oukaïd bear
je sais pas vous sont possibles qui veut
dire maintenant ça fait rien il faut
d'autres je suis fou et de fous rires
nous devinons tous les coups non mes
choix ouais ses filles en résine enfin
lyon s'intéresse aux avantages en non en
fait c'est de la merde
beaucoup d'intervenants pareil c'est la
merde aussi je vais aller voir où qu'ils
aillent la rocqué leeuwen grand accra
notre live in a way ces retours on va
quand même les bonnes si celui-ci il
revient à coup à tout ce qui va mal
après surprise
bien comme f4 ça notre côté allanon
visiteurs il ya une pièce en prix c'est
très intéressant est très content je te
prends ta pièce déjà tu as un cheveu 5
j'attaque la dame alors où elle va si je
vais d'un médecin que je fais dame prend
dame food et rosnef visera d'abord un
jeu voire d'en prendre un bus compris
peut-être qu'il ya eu 4 c'est que je
suivais kyle qu'as-tu fait pions prends
et je fais bouger catch ton ferme tam et
a pu enfin f2 et je suis menacera la
tour pour refaire une autre dame vient
c'est show fera jouer beaucoup trop
compliquée à l'air très content de son
coup leur training
oui c'est ça qui a garé depuis on prend
j'ai quatre pions preuve de la palma qui
a vu quatre de dame prend à chaque fois
puis on prendra le détour ya tous les
effets un question est ce qu'on peut
faire autre chose que dame prendra m'en
fait pas tellement ce que dame croit un
choix s'est fait menaçant banquiers
prend il vous prend maintenant bon j'ai
six projets cinq ans que je me demandais
ce contrôleur ce pion des 4 ou pas mais
je ressemble cramique est mieux là ce
qui avec le four en p4
ça va se jouer à une sorte tempo c'est
vrai le temps de construire tous qui
veut construire on pousse tous furent
fixées
ça va être chaud c'était moi pour faire
pousser de tout ça je sais pas mais bon
là on va avec les blancs c'était le
temps de faire tour 4 au tour chez pathé
renn ton roi tu peux vite tout bloquer
quoi votre
mais ok partie intéressante on ya combat
pour prendre des deux tu vas t'en des
cinq occasions
ouais ok peut-être aux à la une une
éventuellement ce que la ci prend 1,5
on va tout prendre 5 qui va leur prendre
des cas pas dans une finale deux tours
qui normalement est égale 1 toute façon
il ya pas de fin
s'il fait c'est simple soit versé ces 5
va faire cailler prend et on va revenir
en c4 et on va taper macairois et froid
et il sera tendent l'oreille droite est
obligé de prendre 5
heureusement y'a pas re cadeau si tu
prends ses quatre marques et je te
prends enfin tu peux faire re 4 mais bon
on ne perd pas de pièce ça je dis tu
pensais qu'à je te réponds pourquoi fort
que je tourne depuis recife celle ci
soit la protéger c'est le pion qui
demande à notre jeu mais du coup petit à
précision je pense de chroniques qui a
laissé le roi blanc s'activent tiens
c'est quelque chose qui n'existait pas
au début si jamais rongeot direct est
pressenti mariage gay le fai retour ces
cinq participants ce tour des cinq
faudrait pas tout de suite
pour ces quatre heures mais pas
réfléchir je me donne les viols de
pyongyang des machins en tout cas allant
de passionnés par la partie eva partie
du coût le moins de pièces jouent
beaucoup mieux mais je maintiens maria
derrière du coup tu prends des photos et
filmé une photo que les comprends que
c'est le climax des trucs mékrali il se
dit qu'est ce que je fais où je mets ma
tour non mais c'est sûrement ok et gamme
mais je pense qu'en terme de body
language c'est très mauvais de réfléchir
autant de temps à ce moment là enfin
genre de base france fait toujours ses
cinq trois et six étudiants mais que bon
bain d'entre eux sont venus mais on
glisse comment ça il est bien pour
pousser ce genre de finale surtout qu'il
va faire tourner autour c'est 5.6 jaf
énormément enfin pas tu as perdu 1033
fin en gros f4 dégage
un ok mais ça peut pas faire c'est nîmes
ça mais si tu joue parfaitement ces
images fait tour c'est si c'est vrai
mais en fait il veut envoyer la tour des
huit faire trois des quatre matchs et
hop c'est ici se fait retourner si je
vais bien je serai toujours encadrés
chaque côté à tous mais je suis horrifié
jamais un mot qu'il fait c'est ça je
m'enferme à tour ses cinq harmonies me
faire mal et je garde les nanas qui est
tout est ok mais toujours là au temps là
on va y aller ou alors fait heureux
quatre noms mais roi des six ok on va
faire une très technique quoi pour
technique pour toi non non non monsieur
je veux dire c'est que dure a commenté
dans le sens où chaque coup est vraiment
important se fera réfléchir
bon bah du coup oui nous aussi on a eu
un jeu répète les coups je te propose
pas nul
j'ai trois fois une position tient kyle
lowry réfléchi et très content le prix
affiché est survenu banon et je te
propose ce matin pose nue ultralisk
jobboom
non répond volaille partout